we really are living in canceled culture
right now how the hell did parasite win
best picture at the Oscars freaking wolf
culture is Rotem are talking about all
the TV shows and movies that have been
delayed or canceled over the coronavirus
oh alright that Peter Stormare jokes
getting old anyway Peter Stormare that's
the guy from like Fargo and and the Big
Lebowski and the Minority Report and
stuff I think you're thinking of Robert
storm how confident are you about that
there's restrictions on travel going on
right now live show
banning audiences everything is getting
canceled everything's kidding every way
is that do you want to go to is not
happen other events that we were
scheduled to go to one specifically
today has gotten canceled there was a
Wonder Woman 1984 event coronavirus to
rotavirus it's a conspiracy to hate DC
the Disney paying for this it's damned
Republicans controlling everything
please be safe out there it's like fine
line you got a try to ride where you
don't want to like walk around just
freaking out all the time constantly
paranoid but you got to be cautious you
do have to be safe check your
information this is yeah well I don't
mitt like anywhere I go now I I went to
the gym the other day and I just touched
my face and the natural thing you have a
beard and I was like oh no have I done
it oh my god yeah it's a scary feeling
yeah almost everywhere I go then even
when I went to the gym they have those
hand sanitizers and I just like push it
with the elbow go to my hand that's the
new handshake it's just the elbow now we
got so many movies and things being
delayed Broadway they're canceling all
audiences all shows have been canceled
museums are shutting down anything I
think over 250 people that's
non-essential I was watching Seth Meyers
Stephen Colbert Jimmy Fallon they're not
gonna have life's to do what is this
like the writer strike all over they're
delaying the shows and then of course
all these big movies are being pushed
it's funny because Mulan just got pushed
we don't know exactly when yet I was
listening to screen junkies news and
they were all going around the panel
saying oh they won't push to Milan they
just lose all this money by this point
some people were surprised and it
already has been pushed considering that
the coronavirus started in China so yeah
they were talking about how they won't
push it they lose all this money and
then like Milan has already had enough
of its controversy due to its lead star
driving that episode was done at least
when I turn it off suddenly I go on
collider.com and I see Oh Mulan has been
pushed
they've also pushed New Mutants as well
oh they push antlers a New Mutants man
can't catch a break no no man they
didn't get they refuse now they're down
to a pg-13 and that that movie is gonna
come out in 2024 it's just delayed
constantly basketball games are being
shut down yeah I think the NHL is still
going strong for the moment although
just no one's showing up audience is
canceling the NHL and then fast and
furious nine that got a major push yeah
that got 11 months 11 months and it's
taken the fast ten slot all things
considered when you hear like oh man
they're pushing it a year that sounds
kind of crazy
they've already reserved that slot for
all the different fast and furious maybe
some both on the same day I'm very
fascinated to see how the marketing will
unfold for this because that first it
was just like a few movies right like no
time to die I remember we were at
Burbank for a showdown event and they
got this giant banner just right across
the street with the sign they put this
sign up everyone is driving ears out of
the impression the next Bond movies
coming out in April yeah but that was
just like a couple of movies at that
point yeah so it was kind of concerned
for no time to die thinking are people
gonna realize this is not coming out
they're actually gonna come out you know
that some people aren't gonna realize
this but now that all these movies are
you pushing now everyone's probably
hearing about it I'm very curious to see
what the future of trailer reaction
marketing is gonna be yeah well because
that's the thing as they say you know
pandemics and epidemics like these take
you know a month or two to get under at
least some kind of containment so that
we can kind of go back to normal life
generally and and that makes me wonder
if we're going to see more gradual
pushes cuz so a lot of these don't have
rescheduled dates I mean fast does but
you know are we gonna get a glut of
movies next year I or are we gonna ya
see them trickle out in a you know more
truncated fashion for the rest of only
20 as the moment of filming this Black
Widow hasn't been delayed I think
they're waiting a little bit of time but
I'm pretty sure Black Widow will
probably get delayed considering the
fact that this only seems to be getting
worse I have these are these face masks
great for reaction yeah I had to hunt
with just one of these boxes down I
murdered six people business I went to
many different stores I called around a
bunch they were only like we can sell
one box to one customer at a time I'm so
sorry you can only get one box and do my
best to be safe I'm a little skeptical
myself to go to a theatre people at
theaters already annoy me this is and I
already get annoyed when someone goes to
the theater who clearly has a coffee
yeah we don't go to the theater if you
have a cop that's just disruptive I know
you're sick you want to catch this movie
but you can wait and now someone has a
cop at a theater I'm gonna be like oh no
oh no we gotta get the hell out it burn
a layer of my skin off quiet place to
got delayed that was the biggest
surprise to me just because that was
next week yeah like it's so on top of
everything like even Mulan got to cancel
their press screenings and or at least
you know the the next wave of press
greetings and quietly stews had
everything go out you know so they're
gonna have to re advertise Peter Rabbit
- what Wow
I am such a pig Peter Rabbit my fan love
it there are plenty of things that have
suspended production Grace and Frankie
Grey's Anatomy Dale Russian doll no
Falcon and Winter Soldier dammit I was
looking forward to reacting to that this
year that's why that's why Black Widow
is still gonna come out yeah cuz her leg
we we gotta push back Falcon and Winter
Soldier and push back Mulan we gotta
have one Disney movie coming we gotta
anticipate that there's probably gonna
be a shift for a bunch of movies not
just the ones that have like close
release dates to this coronavirus time
bond got pushed to November right and
there's already a bunch of movies that
were like December is The Tortoise Lee
known for how
a crap-ton of movies come out Oscar bait
but also just giant blockbuster come to
come out there so a whole bunch of
movies come out in December a bunch of
movies come out of November you gotta
imagine that the studio's are gonna also
have to readjust those movies who
weren't technically gonna be affected by
the coronavirus because of the fact that
we're gonna have some unusual stacking
of films I wonder if like studios are
gonna try to like coordinate with one
another now to figure this out it would
be cool obviously part of them because
especially in the weird time that we
live in I feel like this global pandemic
is a great way to remind ourselves of
how small the world is and how close we
are together and how there are some
things that are a little bit more
important I wouldn't be surprised if
that happened I'm curious if maybe we'll
see more Wednesday release dates for
certain things because these release
dates are calculated with so much
consideration for who else is releasing
what on which days I would imagine that
if they're not coordinating with each
other they're at least gonna be watching
very keenly and I can imagine Wallace to
see a lot of these slates restructured
significantly
I was watching Marc Maron's latest
Netflix special last night just to get
my mind off things he shot this before
this big coronavirus outbreak it's very
obvious he did he brings up this great
point of the only way we bring people
together is there something terrible is
happening good things don't bring people
together it has to be a terrible thing
that's gonna bring everyone together I
watched this going funny enough it's the
coronavirus right now yeah we're doing
like some ridiculous things while wiping
off the shelves so the paper towels yeah
yeah a lot of people are doing that but
then at the same time we're all kind of
in unison now about the same thing yeah
some are a little bit more mad at others
of like you're being ridiculous but then
at the same time you don't want to be
that guy you want to be conscious you
know you want to treat this situation
with a certain amount of credence and I
think that's especially important in
this moment with this virus because
there's such a disparity between the
kinds of information coming out and the
official words that we're getting the
recommendations of how to respond and
the accounts of how contained or not
this is the onus is on all of us as
individuals to really keep you at that
level head and look seriously at the
risk and also not flip the brick out I
mean Tom Hanks when he got it he just
posted this
morning something else about how they
are doing doing all right now and taking
it day-by-day which is the only thing
you can really do if it's interesting
how much more personal it got suddenly
when Tom Hanks was diagnosed yeah I
didn't know if it was just my algorithm
because you know like I follow a lot of
movie stuff on Twitter and actors and
whatever so I was like maybe this is
just my algorithm making it seem like
that it just got really personal for
everybody I think there is something
about the fact that that like we all
know Tom Hanks funny enough Greyhounds
not getting delayed I know whatever we
make you can go straight to your
payments for the right corner we all
have some type of association to Tom
Hanks we might hear about a bunch of
people dying we might hear about a bunch
of people getting sick we might know
some people who are sick but there's
something in the public sphere with the
fact that it's oh this is someone we all
know it Pierce's that bubble that oh
these things don't happen today yeah
none they're not even like even though a
member wealthy America's not immune to
this and there's no he can't even
protect himself from it yeah it makes it
real I think in India because we have
like a multiple style relationship with
somebody like Tom Hanks it so he is kind
of we have a bond with him because of so
many movies and because he's like your
uncle and he just played mr. Rogers yeah
came from like the pinnacle of
celebrities yeah so I think the fact
that - it went for Tom freaking Hanks
yeah it really makes it tangible in a
special way yeah more I mean I know like
we're kind of a zigzagging around in
this and this talk about it but that's
because yeah my bum that some of these
production delays are happening and then
movies our release dates are getting
pushed around of course am fine okay um
movies are my biggest passion so like
yeah like of course is apartment sure I
would have liked to have seen quiet
place to next week but I'll still catch
it when it comes out it's not a big deal
the thing I'm really concerned for is
the independent movies that are gonna
suffer yeah you know the lower
attendance because of this who maybe
can't afford all of the advertisement
and theater booking rescheduling right
right most importantly what matters is
that everyone does their best to be safe
don't be careless
if you suspect anything about yourself
to your absolute best
take care of yourself for you but also
for that was around you if you're
watching this you don't live on some
castaway island I mean I know we're
talking about timing so you're bound to
interact with someone you're bound to
get close to someone so just be as extra
cautious and extra safe as possible good
hygiene I know a common thing to do in
something like this is be selfish but
also yeah
do your best to look out for others as
well all right guys well which delays
the one that bugged you which one are
you looking forward to subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell lets end this with a nice oliva
it's time for a little shout out for you
something cool out of the box I thought
while I'm up here getting my exercise I
thought I would shout your name out
above the entire valley look at that oh
that's right they know your name now
good news though we're going offroad
they're probably snakes in here but it's
okay so what we do is what we do for you
these look look at the beauty of God's
country and salt thanks to you
in a small way I mean you know I'm here
now I know you didn't pave this but you
know you seem like a person who cares
about the earth and I wanted to honor
that by coming out into the earth to
give you a shout out so one more time
right all right so much love keep
hustling in life
and catch you next month